nous sommes un matin de 1964 à l'École
polytechnique les élèves sont réunis
pour un devoir de math de 5h rien
d'insurmontable pour eux qui sont des
craqus math mais au bout d'une
demi-heure ils se regardent tous
impossible d'aller au-delà de la
première question en fait leur prof leur
a donné un problème impossible les
regards se tournent alors vers ataliie
le major de la promo lui aussi est en
panne mais à un moment il se met à
écrire il règle son compte à la première
question puis il passe à la suivante il
est comme en trans ses sens ne
fonctionnent plus il a l'impression que
quelque chose a pris possession de lui
il remet sa copie au bout de 2h le prof
lui mettra 19 la deuxème note sera
[Musique]
3 jacquesatali est un personnage bien
particulier dans la société française il
est le représentant le plus emblématique
de l'aristocratie des concours diplômé
de Polytechnique de Sciences Po d'inees
de Lena et docteur en économie de
l'Université Paris Dauphine il incarne
la technocratie française plus
précisément ataliie symbolise le mariage
du savoir et du pouvoir qui fait
l'originalité de la technocratie
française son biographe guissidbon le
surnomme le prince des concours après
Sartre c'est un nouveau modèle
d'intellectuel à la française moins
littéraire plus scientifique et
financier en fin de compte
technocratique je vais vous raconter 10
anecdotes révélatrices sur le parcours
d'Atalie si vous ne l'aimez pas
certaines anecdotes vont peut-être vous
faire changer
d'avis nous sommes en novembre 1943 si
ataliie le père de Jacques ataliie est
en poste à Oran la ville portuaire du
nord-ouest de l'Algérie il est appelé au
front en Italie pour combattre au côté
des alliés il est sur le départ quand un
de ses cousins vient lui apporter une
nouvelle tu sais ce que tu as eu Simon
pas un garçon deux garçons en effet
Jacques Atali né le 1er novembre 1943 et
une demi-heure plus tard né Bernard
Atali donc le jumeau de Jacques comme
Jacques Atali est célèbre Bernard vit
dans son nombre mais leur ressemblance
n'est pas que physique Bernard lui aussi
est passé par les grandes écoles
sciencep Lena lui aussi fait partie de
l'élite administrative française lui
aussi a une expérience au plus haut
niveau il a notamment été patron d'Air
France enfin lui aussi écrit des essais
des témoignages et des romans mais
malheureusement pour lui avec beaucoup
moins de succès que son frère les deux
jumeaux Atalie semble proche il
partagent des amis et travaillent
ensemble lorsque les deux jumeaux sont
adolescents la famille habit au-dessus
d'une librairie les clients s'étonnent
de voir Jacques et Bernard partir avec
des livres sans payer en fait leur père
leur a ouvert un compte dans cette
librairie c'est-à-dire qu'ils peuvent
venir prendre les livres qui les
intéressent sans payer et lui règlera la
note plus tard cette anecdote montre que
c'est le père des jumeaux Atali qui leur
a inculqué la valeur sacrée du savoir il
avait voulu lui-même acquérir des
connaissances encyclopédiques il avait
lu le dictionnaire et une encyclopédie
Larousse du début à la fin mais son
quotidien d'entrepreneur ne lui laisse
plus le temps de lire autant il reporte
donc son ambition sur ses fils pour leur
barm mitva la barmitfa c'est la
cérémonie par laquelle les Juifs
célèbrent l'accession à la majorité
religieuse du garçon à l'âge de 13 ans
donc les jumeaux Atali ont 13 ans pour
la Bar mitfa des jumeaux il leur offre
la bibliothèque entière de la playayade
après il ne suffit pas de lire tous les
livres en France c'est le système
académique qui sanctionne le savoir les
jumeaux doivent donc être d'excellents
élèves s'ils ramènent une note
inférieure à 15 leur père les traite
d'enfants fatigués de naissance et ils
ne cessent de leur répéter vous ne
travaillez pas assez pourtant après les
cours les profs particuliers défilent à
la maison l'existence entière des
jumeaux tourne autour du travail ce
régime strict porte ses fruits les
jumeaux excellent dans toutes les
matières lorsque leur mère veut les
inscrire au prestigieux lycée ganson de
sa le proviseur lui dit que c'est trop
tard mais après avoir regardé leur
bulletin il les accepte
immédiatement jacquesatali est en prépa
scientifique toujours à gançon de sali
et ses camarades de prépa n'en
reviennent pas lorsque le prof de math
le fait venir au tableau Jacques résout
la question à la vitesse de celui qui la
connaît par cœur les élèves en perd la
tête il l'accuse de tricher un jour le
prof le met en garde vous allez avoir un
problème le jour du concours vous devrez
convaincre le correcteur qu'on ne vous a
pas refiler le sujet à l'avance mais en
réalité c'est bien ce que fait jaces
Atali il a déjà traité tous les
exercices il achète tous les manuels
tous les bouquins d'exercices et d'anal
qu'il peut trouver et il abat tous les
problèmes de math un par un c'est une
méthode qui repose plus sur la mémoire
que sur la réflexion mais ça fonctionne
elle montre que Jacques Atali est très
pragmatique il est ce qu'on appelle une
bête à concours jusqu'à sa scolarité à
Polytechnique jamais on ne l'a vu dans
un café jamais dans une boom jamais avec
une
fille jacquesatali alors conseillé de
miteran se retrouve dans le même avion
qu'une amie elle lui dit enfin nous
aurons le temps de bavarder il lui
répond oh oui venez donc vous asseoir à
côté de moi à l'heure du déjeuner à
peine assis dans l'avion il déballe
livres et dossiers il branche son
ordinateur à la prise de bord et
travaille à ses livres Jacques Atali est
un boulimque de travail comme pour pas
mal de gens passés par le système
français des grandes écoles ce qui était
censé être une parenthèse un sacrifice à
consentir pour intégrer l'élite
académique est devenu un mode de vie
jacquatali est tout le temps en train de
travailler d'une manière ou d'une autre
il ne dort que 4 5 he par nuit mais il
est plus précisément un bimique de
lecture et d'écriture il a toujours un
livre avec lui et il l'ouvre à la
moindre occasion lorsqu'il assiste à une
conférence par exemple il ne suit que
d'une oreille pour identifier les idées
intéressantes parce qu'il est en train
de lire un livre personnellement je ne
suis pas certain que ça soit la
meilleure manière de tirer le meilleur
de la conférence et le meilleur du livre
mais jacquatali est comme ça s'il ne
fait pas plusieurs choses en même temps
il a l'impression de perdre son
temps jacquesatali a 22 ans lorsqu'il
croise François mitteran pour la
première fois c'est dans un restaurant
discothèque up de Paris Atali encore
étudiant reconnaît le challenger du
général de Gaulle il n'ose pas aller se
présenter mais sa soirée n'est pas
gâchée pour autant car il est en galante
compagnie le jeune polytechnicien est
escorté de Miss France 1966 jacquatali
explore le monde parisien à partir de la
vingtaine il travaille certes beaucoup
mais il ne veut pas être être un ermite
coincé dans les livres il sait que pour
réussir à Paris il faut paraître sitôt
diplômé de Polytechnique il se met donc
à sortir on le voit dans les lieux
prisés accompagnés de femmes magnifiques
il ne renoncera jamais aux mondanité
malgré ses responsabilités des hommes
impliqués au plus haut niveau de
l'administration renonce souvent à à peu
près tout mais jacatali lui multiplie
les dîners ne manque aucun événement
aucun concert répond aux invitations des
journalistes et fréquente tous les
artistes à la mode on peut dire dans la
la terminologie de Bourdieu qu'après
avoir construit son capital culturel
ataliie construit son capital social
pardon pour l'interruption mais j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont ils parlent bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de
grand-chose et oui il y a 24 heur dans
une journée et il faut travailler manger
dormir et sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se gardent bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivé ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo je veux être le Raymond Haron de
la gauche c'est ce que se dit Jacques
Atali à la vingtaine son ambition c'est
donc de devenir le penseur de référence
de son camp politique comme Raymond Aron
le philosophe libéral l'a été pour la
droite au 20e siècle mais Aaron n'est
pas le seul grand intellectuel qui
inspire jacataliie il y a également Marx
qui était comme lui un esprit du monde
c'est d'ailleurs le sous-titre de la
biographie qu'il lui a consacré Marx
était donc comme lui extrêmement curieux
et comme lui il ignorait les frontières
intellectuelles après Marx ce n'est pas
le modèle préféré de Jacques Atal c'est
le penseur auquel son père ne cesse de
le comparer Simon Atalie compare Jacques
à Marx avec fierté mais aussi avec
crainte il me fait le coup de Marx tout
le monde va le haïr et il mourra dans la
misère si vous voulez comprendre ce que
dit le père d'Athalie allez voir ma
vidéo sur la vie de Marx enfin
jacquesalie a également un modèle
intellectuel en économie c'est Joseph
schumpetter le théoricien de référence
de l'innovation
en 1982 sort histoire du temps dans
lequel jacquesatali explique le rôle de
la mesure du temps dans l'évolution des
sociétés salué par les critiques et les
intellectuels le livre connaît un succès
retentissant jusqu'au jour où le
polémiste Jean hderernaliier révèle un
plagiat une dizaine de lignes du livre
d'Atalie sont tiré du Traité du sablier
d'Ernst junger sans guillemets ni
référence aucun des 50000 lecteurs ne
l'avait relevé comment Jean etn alliier
a-t-il déniché l'emprunt et bien il
avait dîné avec atthalie le conseiller
de mitiran lui a dit qu'il écrivait un
livre sur l'histoire du temps et Jean ed
derernaliier lui a alors conseillé de
lire traiter du sabliier d'Ernst junger
le souci c'est qu'après la première
révélation des gens se mettent à
chercher d'autres emprunts et ils en
trouvent un journaliste déniche quelques
lignes de Jacques legof reproduites sans
guillemet c'est un scandale le public
voit désormais Jacques Atali qui est
devenu riche grâce à ses bestsellers
comme un vulgaire plagiaire les gens
sont convaincus qu'il pompe les livres
des autres et les publient sous sa
propre signature mais la réalité c'est
qu'il travaille mal il travaille mal
parce qu'il travaille beaucoup trop vite
il trouve certes le temps d'avancer sur
ses livres par exemple dans l'avion ou à
l'aéroport mais il est trop pressé et
trop fatigué sa véritable erreur dans
cette histoire c'est de ne pas avoir
insisté pour qu'une voire plusieurs
personnes parmi celles qui l'ont aidé
relisent très attentivement le manuscrit
final parce que oui jacquesatali n'a pas
écrit le livre tout seul mais déjà il
l'a admis et en réalité beaucoup
d'auteurs travaillent comme ça avec des
assistant de recherche des Ghost writers
des relecteurs et cetera dans ma vidéo
sur la vie de keines je vous révèle par
exemple que son chef-dœuvre la théorie
générale est en réalité un travail
d'équipe mais Aristote fonctionnait déjà
comme
ça l'intelligence de Valere giscardestin
passé par Polytechnique Elena fait peur
elle faisait peur à François mitéran
mais elle ne lui fait plus peur
lorsqu'il s'affronte à l'élection
présidentielle de 1974 pourquoi parce
que mitérant a jacquatali qu'ilestime
encore plus intelligent que giscar
miteran admire son jeune conseiller et
ataliie adore miteran c'est d'ailleurs
le titre par lequel ataliie est reconnu
à l'époque et par lequel il est encore
reconnu aujourd'hui conseiller de
mitéran mais leur relation débordent
largement le cadre professionnel ils
sont des amis très proche ils passe
beaucoup de temps ensemble ils dînent
souvent au restaurant ils jouent au
tennis ensemble ils voyagent même
ensemble ils refont le monde en marchant
dans Paris la discussion se tend
lorsqu'il parle de la responsabilité de
l'État français dans la Choa c'est le
seul point de tension miteran considère
un peu jacquesatalie comme son fils un
mois après la victoire de 1981 miteran
est le témoin de mariage
d'Atalie nous sommes en 1993 la presse
britannique multiplie les révélations
concernant Jacques Atali le président de
la birde l'organisation internationale
créé 2 ans plus tôt pour aider les pays
de l'Est dans leur transition vers le
capitalisme à en croire les journalistes
du Financial Times Jacques Atali
céderait surtout lui-même il aurait un
train de vie princier au frais de
l'institution il commande rait des
travaux fastueux notamment du marbre
pour les bureaux il aurait également mis
enceinte une collaboratrice russe Atalie
est en réalité victime d'une campagne
médiatique de character assassination
les Britanniques et les Américains
détruisent sa réputation afin de le
renverser le problème c'est que la BIRD
est censé être dirigé collectivement or
Atali n'en fait qu'à sa tête il ne fait
plus que de la diplomatie de haut vol et
finit par se prendre pour un chef d'État
sen est trop pour ses adversaires alors
des administrateurs de l'institution
livrent des informations aux
journalistes qui enquête des espions
suivent Atali à la trace et pourtant la
grande majorité des révélations de la
presse sont fausses il n'est pas
responsable des dépenses excessives ce
sont par exemple les architectes qui ont
insisté pour faire installer un marbre
luxueux de même la collaboratrice russe
et son mari assure que l'enfant est bien
le leur trop tard le mal est fait la
réputation d'Atalie reste entachée
jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en 1998 jacquesatali lance
cital la société qui commercial lise le
cbook c'est quoi le cbook et bien c'est
l'ancêtre du Kindle la fameuse liseuse
d'Amazon que j'utilise personnellement
plusieurs heures par jour sauf que le
cbook d'ataliie est en vente en 2001 et
le Kindle d'Amazon en 2007 c'est-à-dire
qu'ataliie a lancé sa liseuse 6 ans
avant Amazon il avait compris que cette
technologie faciliterait
considérablement la lecture
malheureusement comme c'est souvent le
cas dans l'histoire des technologies
Atali a eu raison trop tôt mais son idée
montre qu'il est un futurologue de
talent jacquatali pense beaucoup à à
l'avenir et il a fait des prédictions
qui se sont réalisées il a par exemple
prédit la carte vitale qui simplifie
considérablement la consommation de
soins médicaux le modèle des plateformes
de streaming qui permet de dépasser le
téléchargement illégal en rémunérant les
artistes ou encore le mouvement dit de
la quantification de soi le fait que les
hommes se servent de la technologie avec
une montre intelligente comme l'watch
par exemple pour mesurer divers aspects
de leur vie comme leur activité physique
leur sommeil leur alimentation et cetera
après certaines de ces prédictions ne se
concrétisent pas par exemple atthalie
avait prédit que les vols commerciaux
atteindraient rapidement les 5000 km/h
mais on est toujours à 1000 il a aussi
prédit des crises économiques qui ne
sont pas
survenus si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personnees cultivé en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur l'istoire
de l'humanité sur l'histoire de France
en économie en science politique en
psychologie en Scien en littérature en
art en religion et en philosophy vous ne
saurez plus jamais à cours de choses à
dire et vous gagnerez la confiance
nécessaire pour briller en toutes
circonstances vous pouvez en savoir plus
en cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore en
tapant directement l'adresse qui
s'affiche à l'écran dans la barre de
recherche mais je pense que la meilleure
façon de vous donner une idée du
programme est d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxens m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouver la dose
d'approfondissement parfaite à la fois
précis mais sans fioriture vincent lui
fait carrément ma pub j'ai d'ailleurs
recommandé votre formation à ma sœur qui
travaille comme diplomate la semaine
dernière elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre à profit dans ses discussions les
connaissances que vous avez diffusé vous
verrez d'autres témoignages comme ceci
dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme et si vous vous inscrivez
vous bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat
une fois que vous aurez terminé le
programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré partie de
ce programme et je serai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée